getting into why I get to talk to the
two of you today I am very curious how
much is his night telling you about
glass and how much is he saying read the
script and let me know what you think
he's not telling us anything
I mean it's that's that's the crazy
thing about being part of you know the
Shyamalan actors is that you literally
know as much the public pretty much like
that is just the way it is and you kind
of I think I spent maybe a year trying
to guess what he was going to come up
with and then I gave up and I just
thought it's more entertaining and fun
if you just let him drop the hints and
the surprises as it goes totally yeah
yeah I mean he called me in like the
spring of last year and was the worst
phone call and then once it was months
before I got to read the script until
like I got handed over to me in Los
Angeles and I had the hard copy that is
such a Shama thing to do by the way he's
like just be available in the fall and
then doesn't say anything else yeah just
like drops the phone and you're like
okay yeah I'll be available in five and
then you get to read the script and then
you get to the table really like each
step along the way there's like a little
bit so yeah he told me that his first
cut of this one was like three hours 10
minutes or 3:20 and that there's a bunch
of deleted scenes yeah right so I'm very
curious from reading the script doing
the table read to what people see on
screen
did you notice stuff missing or was it
just like a normal movie to do I mean
thinking about the table read I don't it
felt like the cinematic version of what
we all did in that room yeah I can think
of like specific little instances like I
definitely can tell we're like there's
there were beats that were longer and
yeah I can think of one specific thing
that but about editing cuts are like
complete scenes mostly editing cuts yeah
but there was like a little stunt that
got cut out that I remember right yeah
yeah but I am curious the the third act
which we cannot talk about has a lot of
twists and turns
yeah um what was your
action reading the script and is like
your jaw on the ground because there's a
pretty crazy [ __ ] that happens yeah I
mean I think I was I was so excited to
get this script it was handed to me by a
very scary looking man that I'd never
seen before in a manila envelope in my
hotel room and I was like okay so I kind
of I raced through it and by the end I
could not flip the page as fast enough
as okay but then what but then what but
then what and then watching it happen in
real life in front of your eyes that's
pretty spectacular like you definitely
go home and think what did I just see
number one and number two how am I so
privileged to have been able to see what
I've just seen that feels pretty cool
you